يوصل معرض اكس بو الحاج جلساته ونقاشاته
لكل ما يتعلق بامور الحج ليومه الثاني وسط
حضور عدد من المسؤولين والوفود من عده دول
حول العالم واكد عدد من المختصين في
منظومه الحج والعمره خلال مشاركتهم في
المعرض على دور المنصات الرقميه في تقليل
الوقت المستقرق لانهاء اجراءات القدوم
خلال اقل من ثلاث دقائق وذلك ضمن مبادره
طريق مكه احدى مبادره برنامج او برامج
رؤيه المملكه 2030
جميله العنود العبدلي تعطينا شيئا من
ملامح موسمي حج هذا العمل 2023
الى وضع الطبيعي دون قيود او شروط وبنفس
الاعداد لمواسم ما قبل الجائحه و وفقا
لاخر احصائيات الرسميه لجائحه كورونا فقد
وصل عدد الحجاج لعام 2019 الى نحو اثنين
ونصف مليون حاجه لكن مشاهدينا ماذا عن
الاشتراكات المرتبطه بالتحصين الحجاج
القادمين خارج السعوديه وزاره الحج
والعمره بينت العربيه انه يشتر التلقي
الحاج ثلاثه تحسناء ضد كرونا ضد الحمى
الشوكيه اضافه الى لقاح الانفلونزا
الموسميه وهو ينطبقوا على حجاج الداخل كما
اعلنا سابقا وتشهد مدينه جده مشاهدينا
استمرار اعمال اليوم الثاني من معرض
ومؤتمر اكسبو الحاج وذلك لمشاركه واحده
و80 متحدثا من القطاعين العام والخاص
ووفود من سبعه او سبعه وخمسين دوله حول
العالم العمليه لتحسين تجربه الحجاج
نعود للمذكر بما اكده وزير الحج والعمره
الدكتور توفيق الربيع انه حج هذا العام لن
يشترط فيه حد اعلى لاعمار الحجاج والذي
كان مقررا في العام الماضي عند 65 عاما
كما كشفت او كما كشف الربيع خلال كلمته في
معرض اكسبو الحاج عن تخفيض تكلفه التامين
على حجاج هذا العام بنسبه ثلاثه وسبعين
بالمئه لتصبح عند 87 ريال فقط
بشارتين
في هذا اللقاء
البشره الاولى
عوده اعداد الحجاج الى ما كانت عليه قبل
الجائحه وبدون اي قيود على العمر
بعثه من اي دوله في العالم عاده ترتبط
بمؤسسه خدمات واحده
في خدمات الحج
ولتعزيز التنافسيه
وتطوير الخدمات وتعزيز الان وابتداء من
هذا العام اي بعثه الحج اي مكتب حج من اي
مكان في العالم يستطيع التعاقد مع اي شركه
مرخصه تحقق المتطلبات اللي يحتاجها حجاج
هذه الدوله
في معرضي ومؤتمر اكسبو الخجل 2023 حيث كشف
محافظ هيئه الحكومه الرقميه احمد الصويان
انه جرى اصداره اكثر من 750 الف تاشيره
عمره لمعتمرين افراد خلال اقل من شهرين
منذ بدء موسم العمره الحالي مضيفا بان من
اولويات هيئه الحكومه رقميه دمج من الصوت
والتحول من 36 من الصافي قطاع الحج الى
منصه نسك مشيرا الى ان منصه نوسه تقدم 100
و21 خدمه تتنوعوه بين قطاع الاعمال
والافراد لخدمه 30 مليون شخص
من قدام من مقر المعرض والمؤتمر ينضم
الينا المهندس محمد ابو الخير اسماعيل
رئيس التنفيذي لبرنامج ضيوف الرحمن مهندس
محمد حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه خليني
ابدا معك من المعرض يعني معرض اكسبو حجم
لماذا هو مهم لخدمه ضيوف الرحمه
حياكم الله استاذ خالد
الحجاج الى الاعداد الجميع
منصه او خليني اقول القبه التي يجتمع
تحتها صانع القرار
خدمات الحج والعمره يجتمع تحتها كذلك
ممثله المستفيدين من شتى انحاء العالم
لمناقشه كافه الخدمات وكافه الترتيبات
التي تتعلق بالحج ااا وخدماته نسعى من
خلال اكس والحج بالشراكه مع كافه الجهات
التي تعمل فيه الى الفروج بافضل طريقه يتم
خدمه ضيوف الرحمن فيه بشكل ابتكاري وتقني
ونحاول ان نقدم افضل الخزانات لهم من خلال
من خلال مقدمي سلسله من مقدمه خدمات
والشركاتهم
بالنسبه البرنامج ضيوف الرحمن
اهم التغيرات التي احدثتها مع الشركاء
والى اي مدى يمكن ان تنعكس على رحله الحاج
هذا العام وخاصه مع عوده الارقام الى ما
قبل الجائع
لعلي ابني في هذه النقطه استاذ خالد
علامات بذكر سابق وبعد تفضل في ميعاد
الشويات الا وهو منصف نفسك وهي تحد احد
مبادرات برنامج خدمه الضيوف الرحمن والتي
نسعى من خلالها الى تقديم تجربه رقميه
مميزه جدا للحجاج والمعتمرين كذلك همم
التنوين على واحده من اكثر المبادرات
الناجحه الخاصه بقياده وزاره الداخليه
مكه والتي ااهل اجراءات قدوم الخاصه
بالحجاج همم الجهود بفضل الله تعالى كبيرا
يتشارك معنا فيها القطاع الحكومي بشكل
جلالات المدنيه والعسكريه وكذلك القطاع
الخاص والقطاع الثالث من ضمن الاشياء كذلك
التي نسعى الى تقديمها بشكل متميز هو
تاهيل العاملين في همم قطاع الحج والعمره
ااا بما يجعلهم يقدمون الخدمه ويتعاملون
بعد الحجاج المعتمرين بشكل راقي يتواكب مع
جهود المملكه العربيه السعوديه وما تبذلوا
في خدمه المجال
الكافات الخدمه التي تحدثت عنها ومساله
ايضا اثراء التجربه ضمن برنامج خدمه ضيوف
الرحمن وضمن التوجه ايضا في في رؤيه
المملكه 2030 مثل هذا التجمع اليوم كيف
يمكن ان يسهم في تحقيقه تحقيق هذين
الهدفين او اهداف بشكل
شهرين قرابه الشهرين تم اطلاق ثمانيه
مواقع تاريخيه
تبداها للزوار
من خلال هذا المؤتمر عملنا على وجود همم
جناح متكامل يشرح هذه التجربه عن طريقه
السينما الاندونيسيه حتى يستطيع ممثلي
الحجاج وكل من يزور هذا المعرض من استشعار
هذه التجربه يعيش وهذه التجربه وكانهم
داخل هذه المواقع همم التاريخيه همم اعطاء
هذا البعد الذي يتعلق وتوضيح هذا البعد
الذي يتعلق باثراء التجربه انه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
المعتمر لا تتصل فقط على اداء النسب
بالشكل الامثل وانما تمتد كذلك الى ان
يعيش وتجربه ثقافيه ترسخ في اثناءهم همم
ويعود بها بافضل الذكريات الان في المعرض
مثلا هذه الموجوده الان كيف ممكن تقدم
الخدمه او تجذب ربما شركات المهتمه خارج
المملكه في تعاقدات معها في مساله كذلك
انه تكون رحله همم تؤدي الغرض همم يعني
دينيا وكمان تثري تجربه هذا الشخص الذي
يصل الى المملكه من عند الجوانب ومجالات
كما تفضلت
المشاركين في هذا
[موسيقى]
الاكس بوكس صحه تعبير يزيد عمي 200 خدمه
استاذ خالد لا تشتمل فقط على الجانبيه
ولكن كذلك جانب الخدمات المصاحب لاحتاج
والمعتبرين
في البرنامج درسنا ما يزيد عن 100 و90
نقطه اتصال للحجاج والمعتمرين نسعى من
خلال هذه الشركات ومن خلال كذلك القطاع
الحكوميه انه نوفر سلسله كامله
التي تتبعها المملكه العربيه السعوديه
المعتمر رحله متناغمه ومتكامله همم
تكون بجانب الامن والطمانين والصحه في
المقام الاول وكذلك يخدم فيها الحاج على
مدار الساعه احدث
ال- الاشترافات وافضل همم المعاجم